MICHEL DEGRAFF: So at
the end of the course,
what I've been wanting--
and I think that was achieved
for the greater part-- is
to have students become very
analytical when it comes
to the use of language,
race, religion,
gender, as technologies,
technologies
to create hierarchies of power.
But if you think of something
that Steven Biko once said,
Biko once said that the most
efficient tool of the opressor
is the mind of the oppressed.
So after the students to
understand how when you grow up
in a society where there
are various hierarchies that
are imposed on that
society based on tools,
like how we perceive race, how
we perceive language varieties,
how we perceive gender,
how we perceive religion,
and we ourselves--
both myself as a faculty of
MIT, but also the students,
are students coming from
different social groupings--
we bring those
hierarchies with us.
And often, it's implicit--
not aware of that.
So at the end of the course, one
thing which became clear to me
is that the students
became more aware of how
these cultural phenomena
and the use of them
and the position of them are
used as tools to maintain
those hierarchies.
So what became
clear to me is that
towards the end of the
course, the students
were indeed very self-conscious
of the uses of culture,
of race, of religion, of
issues about migration
in creating those walls.
And I think now they
have tools that they
can use to break those walls
within themselves, but also
within the social groups.